where people rip on bob larson who that
is
bob larson is he does exorcists
right yeah he's probably a great guy
he's a great guy and if you go on the
mechanic basically if you go to youtube
right there's so many people possessed
by demons right yeah so now that's a
great place to find them too i'll agree
with that don't you good and they're on
tick tock yeah yeah they're on tick tock
as well bro right yeah but bob larson
right if you're you know there's
different kinds of demons beelzebub you
mean yeah yeah there's a demon named
john how do you just how do you
determine if something is a demonic
possession if they're just on flakka
with a flakka saka is a drug that makes
you act like you are but no this is a
midwest this is like on a sunday at a
church man
people are just sitting there like and
poblars and we'll walk up and go i feel
you know i mean some persian demon
inside you persian oh yeah
man things are getting there does it
look yeah this guy look it up
turn it up bro oh you gotta put the
headphones on he's just for men i bet oh
that's him here we go see
he's
waiting he's ousting a demon
he's the possess bro
put your headphones on if you want to
hear it
[Music]
look at the lady behind him yeah he's
scared
that's some jewish guy i think huh
always getting the jew
is he really no dude he cannot do it
look at the black lady behind him she's
like i shouldn't have sat on this
yeah she's like when does this thing
drop off
this is real though man wow and it's
like for me it's like if i was went to
that i would love to go back
you can witness things
stand up
oh this is like simon says but for
people that are really having a tough
time
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
there we go
look at that lady looks like kid rock in
the back
is that marilyn rice scope go back a
half because i'm here to literally
go back half a second right there oh
you're right it kind of it is better
than rice
that right there that's her that's mary
lynn rice cup man
what the [ __ ]
look at him that is her
she's a great actress
yeah yeah
oh i know what's going on yeah yeah so
you know i mean some people get
possessed and there's dudes like bob
larson you know i mean helping out
people right and people rip on them
would you be a pal could you ever find
yourself in a pastorship do you feel
like bobby or kalila i feel like there's
a calling yeah yeah i mean i feel called
too could people love you you know i
could see you find really finding a way
to really and i mean i think you do it
some with podcasting because you're like
talking to people and you're providing
us fun environment for them yeah i think
i'd be a good sermon i could go up and
just do a sermon yeah and i think that i
could be riveting and i think i can i
have things to say you'd have to get on
a phone book i bet that that thing you
know no offense or they put a step in
probably no we you know they do that no
they call them no but they call them
apple boxes bro yes they get after wait
no you can um very
you can just extend your legs now
apparently it's you don't have to travel
to china to get your legs brothers and
sisters jesus brothers and sisters yes
pastor
don't talk young man of the son of the
lord right we are connected with energy
here together and we are one with each
other i like 1995.
give me 19.95 put it in the bathroom
sigma new right
and then everyone puts 19.95 in the
basket right and i'm you know we make a
little money right so i can get my
clothes and i have a nice oh not the
year 1990 no i need money okay is that
too low
i don't think brothers and sisters yes i
can say that good
i have that memorized that's pretty good
yeah yeah yeah yeah do i say brothers
and sisters or
family no brothers and sisters family of
thy kingdom thy come pronoun pretty cool
of different pronouns
[Music]
yeah
right
hey brothers and sisters right this
young man is possessed by do you mean
i'm possessed by jesus christ
no
my friend the anti-vedai
the
anti-anti-die
right and then i'll do what bob loves
i'll hit you with the [ __ ] bible and
then what do i do well you go into
because you're possessed so you're
talking about revulsion yeah yeah you're
going your eyes would roll back yeah and
do that
i'll start yelling right and then
right you start fibbing and then after
as
and then after the church right you and
i are giggling in the back because we we
did it yeah i mean we rehearsed it
already but you know what i mean right
that's trickery that's trickery bobby
i'm not talking about that i'm not
talking about stealing from people oh
yeah you're talking about being real
we're not talking about like uh here's
my sister right there they're staying
during the storm they stayed at a damn
hampton and she sent me this
i wonder who's
there's an audience
due to the damage is there audio of
hurricane ida we've decided to stay at
the home too suite oh it's a nice little
place to us they even let our animals
come in
here's our rabbit panda
panda
and that's not a racial slur either
thank you it's a real rabbit thank you
man
here's the kids and the dog oh
animals are welcome
here's the partition to separate
our room from the kids